[Musik]
die champagne namensgeber für einen der
bekanntesten und wohl auch begehrtesten
schaumwein der welt den champagner
hier im ort opern auf der prachtstraße
avenue de champagne merkt man sofort
dass diese region ganz im zeichen des
exklusiven stimmungsmacher es steht
über 100 champagner häuser haben sich
hier im nordosten frankreichs
angesiedelt jedoch nur die wenigsten
kennt man auch bei uns
[Musik]
wer jedoch die ganze champagner kultur
authentisch erleben möchte der fährt
hinaus aufs land ins herzstück der
champagne nach lumino sie eines der
bedeutendsten weinanbaugebiete hier
reihen sich fast endlos die rebstöcke
aneinander die fast unscheinbare
gemeinde ist ländlich geprägt und man
vermutet nicht dass sich hier eine der
exklusivsten champagnermarken verbirgt
salon für kenner der olymp
[Musik]
madame campo gewährt uns einlass und
führt uns durch die berühmten gemäuer
und weingärten von eugène im salon
[Musik]
am anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhundert
angefangen hat und
er wollte seinen eigenen champagner
herstellen
einen schon beinahe der
für die ewigkeit bleiben würde ein
champagner der
immer noch seine frische hätte nach
30 40 oder 50 jahre was total anders was
total unterschiedlich von der
am anfang kreierte mission salon den
champagner nur für sich und seine
freunde nur wenige flaschen wurden
abgefüllt und das beste war ihm gerade
gut genug
nur die wenigsten jahrgänge waren es
wert überhaupt gekeltert zu werden
dieser philosophie bleibt man bis heute
treu
[Musik]
hier wird hier werden die weine nicht
gemischt sondern
es ist eine einzige weinlage dominici
roche eine einzige traube chardonnay und
aus einem einzigen jahrgang die auswahl
der traube die auswahl der herkunft ja
auswahl des jahrgangs des jahres sind
natürlich
wichtig aber es gibt vielleicht noch was
wichtigeres und zwar die pflege des des
weinbergs
das ist die basis für einen jahrhundert
champagner
zb setzen wir gras an in unserem
weinberg damit die trauben nicht die
zukünftigen trauben nicht verderben das
ist eine art und weise wie man die
pflanze balancieren kann
also wir sind sehr stolz darauf dass
dass wir diese
ökologische umweltfreundliche kultur
haben damit wie wir besser die die
pflanzen respektieren können den boden
respektieren können und endlich den
kunden nach respektieren können
trotz des außergewöhnlichen aufwandes
wurden seit gründung des hauses nur 38
jahrgänge abgefüllt jeder jahrgang wird
dann in der hall of fame der champions
league des hauses präsentiert
[Musik]
und dass man weiter geht mit 25 28
34 also man versteht dass es einige
jahre natürlich fehlen und der grund ist
das schon beim salon
stellt einfach noch die
die besten jahrgängen auf den markt wir
nehmen nicht jede auslese sondern nur
die besten die die lesen wo man die
besten
die beste qualität kriegt und das war
zum beispiel der fall für diesen
unglaublichen
59 das war ein sehr heißes jahr
wir haben genug
bekommen und aber auch einen schönen
säuregehalt was für uns sehr sehr
wichtig ist diese ausgesprochene rarität
steigert natürlich auch die
begehrlichkeit doch nur wenige kommen in
den genuss des perlen am gaumen zu
verspüren so knallen die korken von
salon zum beispiel im elysée-palast und
bringen präsidenten wie staatsgäste in
verzückung
wir setzen unsere prickelnde safari fort
und geben den geschmacksnerven erste
streicheleinheiten bei der verkostung
einer weiteren traditionsreichen marke
dollar ebenfalls in new jersey ansässig
das haus wurde bereits 1760 von francois
de la mort gegründet hier erhalten wir
auch die wichtigsten champagner fakten
[Musik]
ein klassischer blöd ist ein wein der
aus verschiedenen jahrgängen aus
verschiedenen lagen aus verschiedenen
rebsorten dargestellt wird
zusammengesetzt wird
das heißt es gibt normalerweise drei
verschiedene jahrgänge
und drei rebsorten pinot noir dominiere
und chardonnay und mehrere lagen das
heißt verschiedene ortschaften in der
gegend die die die reben stammen aus
verschiedenen
orten was wir hier einen grünen eine
lage das blabla heißt heißt ein
champagner der ausschließlich mit der
weißen rebsorte hergestellt wird und
zwar die einzige weiße rebsorte man hat
hier viele viele frische
viele mineralität auch also ein perfekt
ab der blonde promi team ist dann die
königsklasse er umfasst nur einen
jahrgang von einer rebsorte und einer
lage
und hier im kellergewölbe lagern die
schätze in regelmäßigen abständen werden
die flaschen gedreht rütteln im
fachjargon
das flaschendrehen ist ein wichtiger
prozess dass nur ein ganz bestimmtes
ziel verfolgt
nichts für schwache szenen bei über 1000
flaschen am tag
verschiedenen
jahrgängen die bei seiner hergestellt
werden
und josi mache ich die tür auf und sind
hier die ältesten champagner
flaschen von salon zwar die ältesten
auch die von 1928 sind also die ältesten
flaschen dass sie wirklich mit
diesem jahrgang zählt salon zu den
jüngsten häusern in der champagne hat
aber die meisten in geschmack und
qualität längst überholt
und jetzt erleben wir einen spannenden
moment und zwar die geburt eines
eines schon bald einer champagnerflasche
der wein wird zwar von der hilfe von
seiner hilfe befreit
und das zeigt uns
gerade antoni und
eine höchst feierliche geburt die
natürlich stilecht im kellergewölbe
gefeiert und begossen wird die
geburtsstunde wird mit spannung erwartet
ist sie doch auch ein gradmesser für den
gesamten jahrgang
[Musik]
bringt in einer shopping die spannung
bringt die reinheit bringt dir um
champagner die von chardonnay gemacht
sind haben immer eine tolle eleganz
viele komplexität und eine große
möglichkeit zudem zeigt zu dauern
so jetzt wird es zeit eine kleine
kollektion von de la motte und salon zu
verkosten im stylischen ambiente rückt
der zeitpunkt mehr in dem einer der
besten blonde blossom gaumen prickelnd
wie champagner freunde ein höchst
aufregender moment entsprechend
fabelhaft und lyrisch gestaltet sich
auch die analyse jetzt verkosten wir ja
schon beim november 2007 konnte blog
2007 waren ja der reife hat den
durchschnitt war und auch mit mehr säure
das ist ein kräftiger wein das ist ein
männlicher auf ein sozusagen und meine
ich dass man richtet durch die sehr
warmer marmelade gelbe früchte und
marmelade errungen zum beispiel durch
diese neue kraft im mund diese hohe
identität
diese spritzigkeit diese säure die den
wein weiterbringt
sind bisher außergewöhnlich aber jedes
mal dass ich den wein verkostet es
erinnert mich an diese studenten jahren
als ich zurück nach hause um sechs uhr
morgens kamen und die party syrien der
straße würde gleich geöffnet und das
richte von croissants und
chocolat von paramount alle diese
batterie
genussregionen die frische morgen kommen
es gibt auch auf
im plus diese weiße blumen aromen ein
bisschen wie ein feld im frühling
das ist ein anwender sehr einfach zu
trinken
so ist champagner offensichtlich nicht
nur genuss sondern beflügelt manchen
gourmet zuwarah poesie der champagner
ist die krönung der wein veredelung
entsprechend veredelt er auch feinste
speisen und menüs
kein wunder also dass gerade die
sternegastronomie den champagner auf die
rezepte liste stellt wie hier das
tantris der gourmet-tempel mit
kultfaktor
spitzenkoch hans haas ist mit zwei
sternen geadelt entsprechend können wir
uns auf ein außergewöhnliches gericht
mit champagner freuen
sitzung steht auf dem plan und der
meister ist bereits fleißig am werk
jeden tag tüftelt er an neuen
geschmacksnuancen und hat sich auch für
unsere champagner speise etwas
besonderes einfallen lassen der fisch
wird mit eingefüllt und speziell
zubereitet
nun mal jeder bedient dieses puzzle
diese methode ich immer auf diese weise
schönste die
dadurch vor jahren habe ich dich schon
mal entwickelt und werden täglich ist
es ist eigentlich ohne war mit dieser
folie also über diesen sich darüber
macht nicht nur zu und stellt es dagegen
bei tk zwischen 98 grad
15 und 20 minuten
und sollten sie zu hause so ein delaware
mal haben dann ist das optimale oben hin
auf die idee des hineinzustellen beim
einzigen die sensation genauso können
die fische machen mit lack sowas ist
wunderbar der sonst so sind wir drucken
und so bleibt es wunderbar saftig
während der fisch mit einem bauch sanft
guard setzt hans haas die feine und
elegante soße an ein schuss champagner
sorgt nun für die erwünschte frische
leichtigkeit und natürlich auch die
französische eleganz
der gipfel der genüsse gestaltet sich
schließlich in form einer kleinen kba
krone auf den fisch
und zwar eine karte ist eine champagner
ist und wie dazu nehmen wir all unser
bild
champagner etwas läuterzucker und
schönen dinge das ganze wird dann
aufgeweicht und sein und die kalte
flüssigkeit gegeben am besten auf weiß
dann möchte ich kurz zurück gerät und
kalt stellen bleibt es so schön so
luftig besucher immerhin werden
natürlich kann man da alle anderen führt
ja auch wenn erdbeeren heidelbeeren was
einem einfällt als gehen wir hier gehen
wir jetzt auch nur mittel in diesen
zucker
und dividenden
es wäre nicht so schön
ddp
das ist ein wahrer ausmacht
der wahnsinn so jetzt kommt der übung
jetzt noch mal in diese schöne suppe
geben wir noch mal bill an frischen
kampagne
und zum schluss kommt hier jetzt nochmal
ganz fein geriebene
frische limetten drauf
berlin
sternstunden im tantris hans haas ist es
wieder einmal gelungen in nur wenigen
minuten eine gomopa auf den teller zu
inszenieren mit kleiner unterstützung
aus der champagne
dort hat man natürlich nicht nur sinn
und geschmack für champagner sondern
auch für andere leckereien wie zb torten
und pralinen in epe hat sich die familie
der leh einen namen für vorzügliche
pralinen und schokolade aktionen gemacht
der franzose liebt die süße versuchung
entsprechend drücken sich viele
passanten die nase am schaufenster blatt
wahre kunstwerke füllen das schaufenster
aus viel zu schön rum gegessen zu werden
[Musik]
und verantwortlich für die süßen träume
ist war sondern der junge patissier hat
sein talent von seinem vater geerbt auch
er ist ein wahrer meister in der
gestaltung von pralinen
jeden tag werden hier bis zu 20
verschiedene sorten gegossen und
dekoriert
jede von ihnen ist eine eigenkreation
oft von anderen kopiert doch nie das
original erreicht seine rezepturen sind
streng geheim und werden in einem safe
aufbewahrt
[Musik]
wasser liebt seinen beruf und das sieht
und schmeckt man auch er ist ganz
besonders stolz hier in eppan er in die
fußstapfen seines vaters zu treten und
die lange tradition weiterführen zu
dürfen
[Musik]
meine familie führt das geschäft hier
seit 1991 damals hatten wir nur zwei
lehrlinge aber jetzt sind wir schon über
20 ich bin seit zwei jahren dabei und
setzte diese lange tradition fort wie
sie sehen haben wir eine große auswahl
an kleinen törtchen und pralinen
das liegt daran dass unsere kunden ganz
verrückt nach schokolade sind in
frankreich ist es ja lange brauch dass
man kuchen gebäck und torten zu jeder
tageszeit ist ganz einfach weil es uns
schmeckt und wie ihr süßes leben
insbesondere bei großen anlässen oder
familien jubiläum
bei diesen bildern kommt jedoch der
verdacht auf dass den franzosen gerade
jeder anlass recht ist herzhaft
zuzugreifen und reinzubeißen wer jeden
tag schokolade ist weiß nicht wie
pralinen schmecken
[Musik]
das hier ist eine der neuesten
kreationen unseres hauses wir haben ja
derzeit apfelsaison und da wollten wir
eben etwas mit apfel und karamell
spielen das passt sehr gut zusammen
als basis haben wir karamell mit
meersalz und darüber ein komplott aus
äpfeln die wir klein schneiden und dann
über nacht im ofen karamellisieren und
darüber gießen wir dann eine vorzügliche
schaum creme die macht das arrangement
luftig und leicht eine art schlag sachen
das ganze garnieren wir dann noch mit
etwas schokolade christie's der mit der
geschmack etwas knackiger und cross
wasser verwendet für seine delikatessen
nur feinste produkte angefangen von der
schokolade bis hin zu den früchten
müssen und gewürzen nur das erlesene wie
kakao aus madagaskar wird hier
verarbeitet
[Musik]
das hier ist auch eine ganz spezielle
kreation unseres hauses das gibt es nur
bei uns wir wollten zunächst nur etwas
aus schokolade machen jedoch ohne zusatz
von gluten immer mehr leiden auch bei
uns unter allergien und darauf reagieren
wir natürlich
also haben wir hier einen echten
schokoladenkuchen aber ohne mehl und lud
ihn darüber eine muss chocolart mit dem
besten kakao aus madagaskar und hier
noch eine schöne lage mit biscuit und
feinster schokoladencreme natürlich auch
mit cacau aus madagaskar
natürlich backt wasser auf salziges und
herzhaftes wie dieses französische
original die so genannte cash ihren
ursprung in lothringen hat
[Musik]
hier sehen sie diese für frankreich
typischen fleisch törtchen es gibt aber
immer mehr vegetarier insofern haben wir
uns auch hier auf diese kundschaft
eingestellt und bereiten verstärkt
gemüse tisch zu
selbstverständlich kommen alle produkte
aus der region nur wenige kilometer von
unserem laden entfernt das ist für uns
sehr wichtig
wir haben hier zum beispiel tomaten
zucchini aubergine je nach jahreszeit
gestalten wir die kids anders eine
kitsch der saison sozusagen
im sommer verarbeiten wir mehr tomaten
und im winter erschienen
was ein virtuose der sich nicht nur als
patissier sondern auch als künstler
sieht und seine werke geben ihm recht zu
schön um gegessen zu werden
[Musik]
befahren wieder hinaus aufs land auf der
suche nach einem weiteren virtuosen luca
werden wir für dich ganz versteckt
mitten im wald betreibt die regierung
eine kleine whisky destillerie für die
champagner schon sehr außergewöhnlich
aber mit der herstellung überrascht er
jeden ein riesiger betonmischer ist der
schlüssel für seinen erfolg eine
pfiffige wie auch geniale idee die
maische für den whisky einzumischen
[Musik]
wir machen ein mail von waltz dem ich
mit wasser und es dauert ca 600 dieser
rolle was wir nennen damit werden wir
das vorstellen wer wir ohnehin um zu
brennen so das bier wird
zwei wochen lang gern und diese
regierung ist gemacht durch hefe aus der
schon beinahe die gleiche wie für
champagner stellung wie sie wie sie
sehen das ist eigentlich schon trüb das
ist die der gärprozess
das ist ein bier aber ohne offen das ist
ein bier zu brennen und das schmeckt ja
nicht wie ein apfelwein und apfelsaft
wissen sie frankfurt
terry ist überzeugt dass er im whisky
noch besser schmeckt mit viel herzblut
engagement humor und begeisterung hat er
sich hier seinen lebenstraum erfüllt und
sich mühsam alle geräte zusammen gespart
[Musik]
und ich habe damit die qualität
hergestellt was ich wollte
es wie gesagt das dauert circa vier
stunden und was kommt danach ist der
feind der ist noch klaren wasser als 70
volumen und wird danach in der mitte der
champagner in der motors in der frische
luft der momentan
gelagert für sechs acht zehn jahren in
fässer seien auch bei der lager vom gti
völlig neue und unkonventionelle wege
es gibt einen grund dafür wieso da ist
weil wir in eine spezielle region sind
das ist schon bei mir aber wir sind
mittendrin in der buck naturell der
moment als das ist ein geschütztes
gebiet wo wir nicht mehr bauen können
das heißt ja ich habe das benutzt diese
container gebrauchte container um
einfach liefern zu können da drin im
sommer ist 40 bis 50 grad celsius im
winter minus 20 grad das heißt große
temperaturunterschied und gleich mit der
flüssigkeit und diese reifen prozess
wird viel schneller als normal seien so
in jede brennerei wie sie sehen wir
benutzen malz und malz bedeutet mäuse
und in jeder brennerei gibt es eine
schöne kzs ist der früh und der ist da
seit zirka fünf jahre und wird
sicherlich mindestens zwanzig dreißig
jahre lang halten weil er fast jeden tag
ein paar
typen wie tiere bereichern die
champagner ihr enthusiasmus und
ideenreichtum sorgen dafür dass die
etwas raue und manchmal unwirtliche
region facettenreicher und mit einem
weiteren farbtupfer verändert
[Musik]
17 jahre ist es her dass er sich
entschloss whisky brenner zu werden eine
kühne idee in der champagne die aber von
erfolg gekrönt wurde
[Musik]
in einem alten jagdhaus kommt er ihn nun
zum gemütlichen teil und erklärt uns
dass dennoch auch ein hauch von
champagner in seinem whiskey steckt
[Musik]
das sind
verschiedene region ihr berliner archiv
sie haben zum beispiel ihr champagner
fässer und jedes mal der fall wird
irgendwas anderes bringen vom geschmack
geruch und so weiter zum beispiel wenn
sie die abayoo 250 südfrankreich ist ein
rotwein freedb rotwein aus südfrankreich
das wird ähnlich wie ein board
reinbringen und jedesmal dieser
geschmack ändert sich und das ist sogar
auf acht jahre alte mia und das ist der
unterschied wir benutzer nur
französischer für sowieso weil ich bin
eine droge ingenieur weinbau ich habe
das sind ja schon planen ja studiert und
diese neue was ich gehabt habe auch in
deutschland ich habe fünf jahre in
deutschland gearbeitet das hat mir
einfach diese technik gebracht und ich
wollte irgendwas hier man pflanzen
weinpflanzen unmöglich verboten alles
und ich wollte von dieser schönen eklat
irgendwas machen und dann habe ich mir
gedacht ja wieso nicht eine brennerei
und wieso nicht whisky und dann so hat
das angefangen vor 17 jahren und ich
will ein unterschied von geschmack wir
wollen keine kopie von der schottische
whisky keine kopie von der irish whiskey
oder aus japan wir wollen ein
französischer whisky und besonders als
er schon bin und alles probiert ich habe
auch nicht eine riesen als wäre ich
hoffe dass komponist aber alles probiert
alles ist mit assange gemacht wiener
schon beinahe an das macht richtig die
unterschied zwischen diese großer markt
von schottischer whisky jurys kinder
weiter und wir diese region das ist eine
spezialität der region und mit malz
gemacht mit unserer eigene quelle und
diese quelle hat ein spezieller
geschmack weil ja sie hat das wasser
sehr wenig
mineralien wie sehr so sehr
wie die wie die arische leute sein und
das macht der unterschied und wir
beliefern damit die gehobene gastronomie
die gast zum beispiel der begas in der
tabelle und diabelli fonds wollen die
präsidentschaft überlief und
verschiedene gastronomie und viele
kleine
die region so charismatisch und
einzigartig wie das ergebnis seiner
arbeit
[Musik]
auch er ist ein unverwechselbarer typ
und man mit passion denn lucky ned ist
der trüffel könig in der champagne wobei
eigentlich seine hündin leila für den
erfolg zuständig ist schließlich ist sie
ist sie mit ihrer schnauze die begehrten
leckerbissen im boden erschnüffelt und
ausgräbt die beiden sind ein
unzertrennliches und eingespieltes team
liebe auf den ersten blick und blindes
verständnis
das verhältnis zwischen mir und dem hund
ist etwas ganz besonderes der hund muss
das gefühl haben die trüffel für mich zu
finden das ist ganz entscheidend
das heißt er sucht die trüffel und
wartet dann darauf dass ich komme
viel eher ist das eine art spiel
zwischen ihr und ihrem herrchen dieses
wechselspiel und die kommunikation
zwischen ihr und mir ist ganz wichtig
über zwei jahre hat wenn er mit seiner
hündin trainiert und ihr beigebracht die
trüffel nur zu suchen und nicht zu
fressen denn auch hunde sind von
geschmack und aroma fasziniert
[Applaus]
so dieser trüffel ist nicht gut das
sieht man hier und normalerweise weiß
sie dass aus
also du musst da noch mal suchen der
hier war nichts los auf geht's los und
suchen
ich habe ihr gesagt dass dieser trüffel
nicht gut ist denn er ist hier in weiß
und außen schwarz
aber ich suche nach trüffeln die hier
innen braun sind und etwas weiß denn das
sind die besonders schmackhaften trüffel
maronen farben dann sind sie top
der hier ist einfach zu der hat keinen
geruch und deshalb lasse ich ihn hier
über die jahre ist benno war richtig
verwöhnt geworden der dritte experte
verarbeitet nur die besten
[Applaus]
letztlich hängt aber der erfolg von lena
ab nicht immer hat sie lust trüffelsuche
zu spielen aber auch bei noah musste
viel lernen
man braucht sehr viel erfahrung und
wissen um den wald und die umgebung
beurteilen zu können
wir haben hier haaseloop
dort hinten buche und auch noch esche in
deren umgebung wachsen auch sehr gerne
die trüffel wenn sie den boden und auch
die bäume erkannt haben müssen sie auch
auf das wetter achten
in der champagne haben wir so rund 600
bis 800 millimeter niederschlag im jahr
und das sind hervorragende bedingungen
für alle pilzarten
diesmal hat sie ihn nicht gegessen aber
wenn die trüffel sehr klein sind und ich
nicht gleich in ihrer nähe bin versucht
sie ist doch immer wieder mal den
trüffel aufzufressen
früher wurden für die trüffelsuche fast
ausschließlich schweine eingesetzt
inzwischen trifft man die nur noch sehr
selten auf der suche an
ich weiß nur von drei schweinen in
frankreich die für die trüffelsuche
angesetzt werden
das problem bei den schweinen ist sie
suchen die trüffel um sie auch selbst zu
essen denn sie haben gerade für die
schweine einen außergewöhnlichen geruch
und so versuchten im letzten jahrhundert
viele bauern ihr glück in dem sie ihrem
schwein ein stück trüffel zum griechen
gaben und dann mit ihnen auf die suche
gingen
aber das problem war sie mussten den
trüffel vor dem schwein finden und
schneiden
sonst würde das schwein den trüffel
fressen
leider hat da schon weitaus bessere
manieren zwar schnappt auch sie manchmal
nach einem leckerli aber in erster linie
will sie ihrem herrchen eine freude
bereiten was jedoch nicht immer geliebt
leider war es nicht ich der hier den
größten trüffel entdeckt hat meine
mutter hat ihn mit einem unserer hunde
gefunden
ich war sehr traurig dass ich ihn nicht
gefunden habe
denn jedes mal wenn du auf trüffelsuche
gehst hoffst du natürlich
dass du den größten findest
der größte wurf 350 gramm
ein stolzes gewicht gewiss auch für
einen stolzen preis in seinem haushalt
benno ein kleines museum mit shop
eingerichtet er zeigt uns wie vielfältig
der trüffel verarbeitet werden kann ohne
seinen charakter zu verlieren
wir haben hier trüffel butter die lässt
sich sehr leicht hinstellen
trüffel butter schmeckt zum beispiel
hervorragend auf toast oder ein tipp
wenn sie freunde eingeladen haben
trüffel butter mit einem glas champagner
sehr gut
zudem stellt benno auch öle sowie
trüffel creme zum verfeinern von soßen
her und ein weiteres bemerkenswertes
produkt
[Musik]
in der champagne verarbeiten wir auch
trüffel zu gewürzen wie hier dieses
trüffel salz
damit verfeinern wir zum beispiel
fleisch beim braten oder würzen auch
unsere komme es damit
in unserem restaurant haben wir ein
spezielles menü mit trüffel kreiert
angefangen bei der vorspeise bis hin zum
bisher
jeder gang wird mit trüffel zubereitet
aber dennoch bin ich der ansicht dass
man den trüffel am besten und auch
intensivsten auf einem frischen und
knusprigen baguette genießen kann
wenn die trüffel butter eignet sich
ideal den trüffel geschmack zu
kompensieren
also um den geschmack unverfälscht zu
erleben empfehle ich trüffel butter oder
krähen bei
diesem anblick erklärt sich auch warum
bei noah gewiss morgen schon wieder mit
leila durch die bäume streift
[Musik]
unser kulinarischer streifzug durch die
champagne führt uns weiter nach tours zu
machen die eindrücke am wegesrand
verraten dass wir wieder auf der suche
nach einer neuen champagner geschichte
sind und die wird uns in einem der
renommiertesten häuser der region
erzählt bei laurent perrier
es gut wurde 1812 gegründete und
insbesondere von bernardo makuch geprägt
dessen bewegende lebensgeschichte man
bis heute in jedem winkel entdecken kann
der bogen aus der römerzeit den sie dort
hinten sehen hat werner monaco hier im
garten wieder aufgebaut
er war ein großer sammler und liebhaber
von schönen dingen mit seiner liebe zum
detail hat er auch den stil von
laurent-perrier geprägt
danach war den menschen sehr nahe aber
insbesondere die natur hat es ihm
angetan
und deshalb investiert unser haus auch
heute noch sehr viel in diese parkanlage
sowie in die umliegenden gärten in
diesem jahr haben wir sogar in london
den ersten platz für die schönste garten
architektur gewonnen eine sehr begehrte
trophäe der preis wurde sogar von der
königin persönlich verliehen
hier sehen sie eine alte weinpresse die
heute natürlich nicht mehr verwendet
wird aber sie zeigt sehr anschaulich wie
früher der wein und schließlich der
champagner hergestellt wurde das ist ein
wichtiger teil unserer geschichte und
deshalb schmückt sie auch diesen park
der erhalt der werte ist ein wichtiger
teil in der firmenphilosophie
[Musik]
hier direkt vor unserem weingut wachsen
auch unsere chardonnay rebstöcke
chardonnay ist der typische wein unseres
hauses er prägt ganz klar den stil und
den charakter unseres champagner er
verkörpert frische eleganz und
feingefühl und das verdanken wir eben
dieser rebsorte
neben chardonnay bauen wir hier aber
auch noch pinot noir an
das haus ernte zu dem die trauben an den
besten lagen der region ein wichtiger
garant für gleichbleibende qualität mit
der die marke gerade unter berna weltruf
erlangt
[Musik]
hier befinden wir uns vor dem großen
ehrenhof wir werden immer unsere
berühmten gäste empfangen prinz charles
zum beispiel war hier schon zu gast und
auch mitglieder anderer königshäuser
aber diese besucher sind für die
öffentlichkeit nicht zugänglich eines
bleibt privat diskret
eine einladung ist wirklich ein sehr
großes privileg
jetzt geht es hinab in das
allerheiligste an keinem anderen ort
wird einem die geschichte von
laurent-perrier so bewusst und
erlebnisreich erzählt wie im
kellergewölbe in jedem raum trifft man
auf eine neue epoche so auch auf die
einführung des großsegler in der
unverwechselbaren flaschenform eine
hommage an die kunst und kultur des
17ten jahrhunderts
[Musik]
wir sind hier in den kellergewölben und
hier haben wir uralte flaschen aus dem
17ten jahrhundert die dem haus
laurent-perrier als inspiration für den
grand circle gedient haben
es ist für uns auch eine reminiszenz an
die zeit ludwigs des 14 eine epoche in
der die kulinarik die kunst und die
kultur in frankreich zu neuer blüte
erweckt worden
im gegensatz zu anderen häusern sieht
man sich nicht aufs siegerpodest in der
formel 1 oder großen champagner gelagen
der prominenz mann verkörpert vielmehr
das familiäre erbe und den geist der
jeweiligen persönlichkeiten und deren
innovationen so war es auch mit perry
die mit ihren visionen und erfindungen
maßstäbe setzte
[Musik]
matt perrier und jean laurent haben die
firma gemeinsam gegründet und ihr daher
auch den namen gegeben als die seniorin
starb als sie das unternehmen alleine
weitergeführt und war hierbei sehr
innovativ so war sie die erste der es
gelungen ist ein besonderes verfahren zu
entwickeln in dem man champagner ohne
süßes herstellt das heißt beim keltern
des weines kommt sie völlig ohne zugabe
von zucker aus
dem keller gehen die jahrzehnte auch
architektonisch fließend ineinander über
fast stylish mutet der reife keller an
[Musik]
hier in diesem raum lagern unsere
wertvollsten schätze der chardonnay und
der pinot noir aus diesen weinen stellen
wir unseren berühmten großsegler her die
beine hierfür stammen ausschließlich aus
gran cru laden aus diesen großen lagen
werden dann die erlesensten chardonnay
und pinot noir reden gemischt die
croisette ist eine mischung aus den
besten jahrgängen den besten lagen und
den besten behandelt hier sehen sie die
fässer mit chardonnay und pinot noir man
fühlt sich hier wie im spiegelsaal von
versailles hier schlummern jeweils 14
verschiedene chardonnay und pinot noir
sorten
dieser gang ist das herzstück des
weingutes
im historischen teil des kellers lagert
der champagner exakt sortiert nach
jahrgängen
ein unüberschaubares labyrinth an gängen
seelen räumen und nischen
über 200 jahre geschichte wird hier
erzählt
100.000 flaschen werten alleine hier
darauf irgendwann einmal stilvoll
geköpft zu werden doch nicht alle sehen
das tageslicht einige flaschen werden
für immer aufbewahrt ein historischer
schatz für die nachwelt
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir in der galerie der mönche
hier hat danach stets eine flasche groß
erklärt aller jahrgänge seit 1959
aufgehoben und sicher aufbewahrt auf den
flaschen sieht man noch den natürlichen
schimmelpilz der durch die hohe
luftfeuchtigkeit entsteht
jetzt wird es auch zeit für ein
geschmackserlebnis
die leidenschaft für den champagner
entfaltet sich spätestens am gaumen so
auch beim ultra britt ein wichtiger
begleiter der nouvelle cuisine
[Musik]
der unterricht ist wie eine schöne frau
die kein make up braucht das liegt daran
dass dieser champagner völlig ohne
zucker auskommt wir führen hier
keinerlei zusatzstoffe zu die den
eigengeschmack verfälschen könnten den
ultra produzieren wir nur in
ausgewählten jahren in denen es sehr
heiß ist da hier die trauben besonders
zuckerhaltig sind und wir keinen extra
zucker hinzufügen müssen
und der ultra brück entzückt auch die
promis
[Musik]
der unterricht ist übrigens auch der
lieblings champagner von kate moss und
warum ganz klar ein glas hat weniger als
50 kalorien das ist die hälfte eines
sonst marktüblichen champagner
wer würde sich bei diesem argument nicht
auch einer champagner diät unterziehen
stefanie experte thomas schreiner zieht
ein kleines resümee
so jetzt haben wir die ganze palette von
laurent-perrier durch probiert und
getestet
wir haben begonnen mit dem ultra britt
ohne zucker der sich perfekt geeignet
zum
genuss auch bei austern bei großen
tieren mal da jod drin ist und kein kein
zucker benötigt wird dann
haben wir natürlich den brit der brit
der als klassischer aperitif zu
verwenden ist und durch das ganze menge
getrunken werden kann locker perrier
jahrgang 2004 ideal für kräftigere
speisen wie zum beispiel kalbfleisch
groß jakl die prestige
aus drei verschiedenen jahrgängen ist
ideal für gänseleber und natürlich zum
abschluss den hoher see die cuvée rosé
aus dem hause mit der besonderen
herstellungsweise die man das ganze
essen über trinken kann und natürlich
insbesondere zu dass er ganz
hervorragend passt
zum ende unserer kleinen gourmet reise
durch die champagne besuchen wir noch
den ehemaligen wohnsitz von bernardo
mappus
ein hauch von versailles in der
champagne so stilecht sein champagner so
authentisch war auch sein lebensstil
[Musik]